bonsoir thomas est ce qu'un gouvernement
américains avancent aussi vers une
vaccination obligatoire pour tous
oui on peut dire que plusieurs étapes
ont déjà été franchie en ce sens on est
loin désormais de la politique
d'incitation qui était en vigueur il ya
encore quelques mois au début de cette
campagne vaccinale alors ce qui a changé
depuis évidemment c'est l'émergence du
variant delta et une couverture
vaccinale aux états unis jugées
insuffisantes par les autorités
sanitaires alors au départ la liberté a
été donnée aux différentes entités que
ce soit des entreprises ou des
établissements scolaires voire des états
d'imposer ou non la vaccination mais
depuis quelques semaines le gouvernement
a donc repris la main en imposant
d'abord aux employés fédéraux de se
faire vacciner puis donc la semaine
dernière de nouvelles annonces de la
part de joe biden qui veut aller encore
plus loin on écoute
il ne s'agit pas de liberté ou de choix
personnel il s'agit de vous protéger et
de protéger ceux qui vous entourent les
personnes avec qui vous travaillez les
personnes auxquels vous tenez les
personnes que vous aimez mon travail en
tant que président et de protéger tous
les américains donc ce soir j'annonce
que le ministère du travail élabore une
règle d'urgence pour exiger de tous les
employeurs pourront 100 employés ou plus
qui emploient ensemble plus de 80
millions de travailleurs de s'assurer
que leurs effectifs sont entièrement
vaccinés ou présente un test négatif au
moins une fois par semaine
alors cette mesure concerne environ 100
millions de salariés américains il faut
noter que les soignants sont aussi
concernés par ces mesures d' obligation
de vaccination et puis maintenant c'est
au tour des soldats des forces armées
américaines de se faire vacciner ils ont
une date limite qui a été fixée au 15
décembre prochain pour procéder à cette
injection alors ces décisions ne sont
fous ne se font pas sans une certaine
résistance des personnes concernées
comme en france il ya une forte
opposition à cette vaccination
obligatoire aux etats-unis cette
opposition elle s'articule notamment
autour de la notion de liberté qui vous
le savez est une valeur chère aux yeux
des amériques et thomas comme souvent
aux états unis l'opposition s'opère sur
le terrain judiciaire avec une plainte
déposée hier par les autorités de
l'arizona
oui le gouverneur républicain de
l'arizona qui s'oppose donc à cette
obligation de vaccination voici ses
propos le gouvernement byden bafoue une
nouvelle fois nos lois et notre
jurisprudence pour promouvoir ses idées
radicales voilà donc pour les
déclarations du procureur général de
l'état mark snow beach alors il ya une
gouverne une comparaison qui a été
effectué par les autorités en arizona
entre le sort des américains qui doivent
donc faire face pour certains à une
obligation de vaccination et les
immigrés illégaux qui arrivent sur le
territoire et qui est évidemment non pas
de preuves de vaccination a montré alors
il ya aussi une affaire dans l'état de
new york puisque un juge de l'état de
new york a bloqué l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants qui devait entrer en
vigueur le 27 septembre prochain au
motif que cette obligation faisait fi à
des motifs religieux qui peuvent être
invoqués par les américains pour
justement ne pas procéder à cette
vaccination est une particularité ici le
motif religieux peut donc être invoqué
pour échapper à cette obligation de
vaccination c'est ce qui est arrivé
notamment dans les rangs de la police de
los angeles la prochaine étape ici aux
etats-unis ça pourrait être les
passagers des vols qui devraient pouvoir
qui devrait bientôt de présenter une
preuve de vaccination c'est en train
d'être discutées au sein de la maison
blanche mais il ya une interrogation
comment vérifier le statut vaccinal des
américains alors que le gouvernement a
promis qu'il mettrait en place ni
passeport vaccinale ni qr codes comme
c'est le cas en france merci thomas
abonnés pour ces précisions en direct de
washington m